i just i think we need to be panicking
about this
erosion in the norm of non-violence
in western liberal democracy
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
and returning guest today is an
independent journalist and the author of
unmasked inside antifa's radical plan to
destroy democracy nice neutral title
there andy no welcome back to
trigonometry
i'm very happy to be here again we're
very happy to have you back andy you've
been doing some really important work we
had you on the show last time
shortly after you were assaulted and we
we talked by antifa and we talked about
that
a lot but since then in april and may of
2020 we saw
uh the blm protest and antifa related to
that
really taking over several city centers
in america and you did some
great work on that so for anyone who
doesn't know what antifa is
who has never heard of this issue before
who maybe frankly hasn't ever seen any
coverage because some of the stuff
you've been posting on social media
from footage from those scenes never
made it to mainstream television or on
news
certainly in this country so just give
everybody a big picture overview
what is antifa what has been happening
in america for the last year
antifa is a violent extremist movement
of anarchists and communists with the
explicit stated
goal of destroying liberal democracies
so
they've seen a significant rise
particularly
since the election of donald trump um
after in late 2016 and instead of just
being a radical left wireless movement
on the fringes they've moved into the
mainstream in america
first through periodic infrequent street
brawls and riots in the cities like
portland
berkeley and seattle escalating to the
point of
throughout 2020
mass simultaneous riots in
dozens of cities of coordinated street
violence
iceland attacks the use of mortar
explosives and even
in the case of where i'm from portland
we had
a homicide a murder and so they've taken
over several city centers
uh i remember chas and they've done
another one in portland uh recently as
well
uh and uh what what is the
because for a lot of people who again
who haven't followed this
it's hard to tell like blm protest
antifa is there a connection there are
these two organizations working together
uh how do you see that part of it they
are working together they do
have different ultimate agendas broadly
antifa are so they're made up of
anarchist communists so they
believe that they can that we can
organize society under communism without
the use of a um a big government or
totalitarian state
so this is why when you look at the
communes that they make like
communes or their autonomous zones you
look at the capital autonomously
otherwise known as chaos you look at the
autonomous zone they have in portland
they will create these sort of lawless
areas where they say that they don't
need the state they don't need law
enforcement they don't need any type of
order that they can take care of
themselves
of course we know they can't take care
of themselves in the case of chaz
we had two homicides there uh several
shootings
uh in the case of portland it was
literally creating a war zone in the
middle
of a residential area in portland um
and you contrast that with blm which is
in
its theoretical underpinnings very sort
of classic
revolution revolutionary marxists who
are about um sneaking into
the institutions uh of the state
and mainstreaming their marxist agenda
so
you know there's a very systematic
attack on free markets from blm
and they're using it under disguise of
racial justice so there's a certain
amount of
overlap in terms of opposition to the
state particularly the united states of
america
opposition to capitalism of course
opposition
and hatred murder hatred and law
enforcement
so because of that there's been a
certain cross-pollination
and you've seen antifa implement some of
the
intersectional ideology that's prevalent
in blm
and also the usage of their chance
black lives matter and all that to the
point now where when i described antifa
at least in america
i use blm-antifa because i really do
think that they are
such linked entities ultimately
their ideologies will clash because one
is calling for
essentially a totalitarian state blm
whereas
antifa is calling for anarchy
so let's find out he wins that one that
would be great wouldn't it yeah that'd
be very very interesting but you know
we've got antifa on one side we've got
blm but surely
we need to take into account that there
are a lot of people who
march for blm who have got no idea about
antifa
who've got no idea about the you know
these
hardline marxist views where do these
people come in the people who just go
along and march and just want to see
maybe
social justice maybe want to see black
people being treated more fairly
yeah so um i feel
i don't feel happy to describe them in
this way but i recall
they're being used as you saw idiots
essentially
so both these movements antipa and blm
use the cloak of racial justice and
social justice
to shield themselves from criticism
so for example um i have spoken
vocally in opposition transfer led to me
being
beaten in 2019 and my family threatened
and
myself continually subject to death
threats and their responses how could
you be
against a movement that calls itself
anti-fascist that if you're against
anti-fascism it means your fascist
if you're against black lives matter
that means uh
you are against black people so
you know that this is what makes these
movements so clever it's a very
uh the branding of it in in the slogans
and all that
allow a certain amount of deflection of
criticism and unfortunately
they've used that very well in that in
um
the media has not really applied a
critical lens
on the violent extremist rhetoric the
violent extremist ideology and their
voluntary streamless actions
so they've been given a free pass
essentially so there are a lot of people
on the left i would say liberals who
obviously when they hear something like
uh being against fascism
being against uh black anti-black
uh racism uh being against a racist
police brutality like these are things
they want to be
a part of and they go out to these
demonstrations
and essentially are used as human
shields in these larger protests that at
a moment's
instance turn into violent riots
um and that's what happened that i
witnessed myself in portland but other
cities
the riots that happened particularly at
the end of may after the death of george
floyd was ostensibly under this banner
of black lives matter and racial justice
but there would there was really no
way for these protests to not be
uh hijacked by violent extremists who
did it
over and over and over and in the case
of portland over 120 days
of daily riots every day
happening every night it since then has
been now
weekly since about september
but this is an issue that's not going
away and people
are assumed wrongly that after
the election win of joe biden in
november that you know this is
this is the end of antifa you know
democrats coming into power that
uh we're not going to see an issue wrong
we had
really bad rights in portland and
seattle uh
just a day after the election
you know we're recording this just on
the heels of what happened on new year's
eve
in portland of uh dozens and dozens of
antifa black block rioters trying to
break into
a government building in downtown with
hammers using hatchets
they came with explosives um they were
throwing explosives at police
uh they were throwing homemade paint
bombs that had been laced with a caustic
substance
so and the thing is like
a lot of people also know my work
through the the ante for mugshots that
i've been posting throughout the year
going through public records finding out
names running out charges
finding the booking photos and i release
all of this and i look into all of it
because
the overwhelming majority of these
people particularly in
left-wing cities have their charges
dropped
so the underlying variables that have
made anti-force such
a destabilizing threat in some american
cities
those variables are still here and they
will remain to be here
even as trump leaves office in a matter
of days
but i just want to touch on so you use
the term useful idiots about these
people who go out
and they go on blm marches and all the
rest of it but it's not just people
these are also corporations andy if you
look at the premier league
which is a football uh it is football
not soccer you need to know that
well you know which is our soccer league
which is broadcast
right around the world we have
footballers taking the knee we have
britain's got talent
where they had pictures of the black
lives matter fist
why is it it's not just individuals but
corporations as well being taken in by
this
well this is what makes the blind antifa
movement
dangerous in my opinion it's not
necessarily these on the larger scale
relatively isolated instances of street
violence
they are isolated at the aggregate level
what makes them dangerous is that the
ideology is mainstream
not just through mainstream democrat
politicians but
you look at corporations you look at
very big
influential figures i mean you know the
mayor of
london uh apparently approved having
these blm
uh fists logos you know blasted out on
your new year's eve uh
fireworks celebrations and that's you
know nobody abouts and either sort of
just
he's all about unity andy yeah right
yeah and
you know blm whereas you know they chant
for police officers to be killed
um in the case of portland nobody
would come out uh to criticize antifa or
blm because well
they believe that these people are
fighting for a noble cause
and this is the thing to these
corporations these
capitalist corporations who have
benefited
immensely under free markets are also
then channeling money to many of these
radical non-profit organizations that
are working really to undermine society
in the case of portland we have actually
one antifa organization called snap
block
who recently got non-profit status and
they actually got 145 000 us dollars
grant through the federal government
that was dispersed to the state of
oregon
and local officials gave 145 thousand
dollars for
ostensibly coded relief and then you go
in the social media and you look
they're posting pictures of police
officers being
drawings of them being decapitated
seeing other
retweeting uh promotional flyers for
riot events earlier this year
and it's like we are funding our own
destructions
here in the west here in liberal uh
democratic states
france has brought up the the
involvement of corporations but
as as you explained to us the last time
we had you on the show one of the
biggest problems in your city in
portland has been the fact that
the mayor is also the police
commissioner
yes uh and so until very recently
he was very much on on their side it
would seem um
and essentially what i want to ask you
is how has this happened andy because
and maybe this is the russian in me
coming out but if people wanted to burn
stuff down
on the streets of moscow it wouldn't
happen
for very long yet this has happened in
america for eight months
how has it been allowed to happen
because we've seen police
officers there trying to do something
about it we've seen even federal
officers i think
coming to some of these places why has
it been possible for these people to
set up autonomous zones like try and
make a new country in the middle middle
of seattle
why how has that been enabled and by
whom so
this is what i mean when i say like it's
like the acts
the consequences of mainstreaming the
far-left extremist ideology of blind
antifa
has real life consequences in that it's
been very strategic
in delegitimizing law enforcement in
america
to the point of where you have police
departments
in major cities like portland
uh seattle new york where they're
essentially hemorrhaging and on top of
that they're being defunded by the tens
of millions so in the case of uh new
york city
one billion dollars was slashed in their
budget with crime
already skyrocketing so there's one on
one level
a lack of resources in being able to
respond
and that's what happened particularly
this year in portland with many officers
either resigning
or tr um taking early retirement from
the
portland police department and uh the
bureau
is unable to bring in uh new officers to
replace what's being lost because nobody
wants to go into
now um what should be a noble
institution policing
uh when it's seen when you're demonized
than when you're dox
um when you get attacked in in
in some unfortunate cases um killed for
political reasons
so yeah there's a lack of resources and
then
there's also the political involvement
in these calculations from things that
the mayor let's say a portland
who's the police commissioner but even
beyond him the city council itself
they exert immense political pressure
over police departments not just in
portland in any city
so even though they are supposed to be
uh separate from one another they are
linked because
if a police department has no political
support from the city council and
elected officials it will really
restrict what they're able to do so in
the case of portland
um in addition to the policing issues
we also have a so-called progressive
prosecutor who is elected so in in the
u.s
um our district attorneys are also known
as prosecutors this is an elected
position so you can imagine if you are
living in a city like portland or
seattle where it's entirely left wing
and
like in progressive there's all the
incentive in the world to be a
prosecutor who's
who will be politically motivated in his
or her prosecutions
that's happened in seattle and
importantly we had somebody new come in
who campaigned on a platform of
restorative justice which means
essentially going easy
on criminals so importantly we've had
over a thousand
rights related arrest arrestees you know
that
more than 90 have had their charges
dropped so
the same people literally and if you
look through um
my posts of the anti-anti-fun mug shots
these people being re-arrested
three four five six seven eight times
and just coming out they're
arrested in jail they get let out with
no bail and they're back out
in the charges or drops they just do the
same thing again but it's not just
portland using that you see that in
other cities
so all of these issues are coming
together to
create um
it's a erosion of the rule of law and
also like
our foundational norms in society one
that we don't solve
disagreements through violence now
people are doing that and to the point
of where
you'll see commentators on news media
you'll see opinion pieces
in our biggest papers of records arguing
that
property destruction is not violence
that is a mainstream talking point on
the liberal left in america
it is over here as well see so
this is what i mean when i in my book
that i say that
this is what makes antifa so radical
radical and dangerous i'm not talking
about
instances of them rioting from one night
or tonight or
you know portland's quite extraordinary
in that we had more than six months a
nightly violence but
it's what it does to the institutions of
liberal democracy
on top of that you're you know you're
having people now
who they're openly
physically assaulting people who have
political disagreements with them and
they're getting cheered
on for it by
frequently politicians mainstream media
they'll turn a blind eye to it
so like i have
um i have a lot of despair in being
in that you know my warnings to the city
going back
in the city of portland and other places
in america going back years i've been
writing about this issue for a long time
i didn't want to be right
in the end not only that was i right i
actually underestimated antifa i don't i
did not think that they could have done
what they did particularly in my
hometown in 2020
but that they were able to carry out six
months of carnage and get away with it
essentially very
very few people have been held
accountable
and one issue is that a lot of them uh
on
can't be identified because of the black
block
um but even then frequently when they
are identified then their charges are
dropped anyway
so like portland is a harbinger for
other places in america and i think more
broadly
obviously what what political trends
happens in america
it's also then exported to your country
i think i mean blm has taken root
in britain and blm thank you for that
and um
we're very i'm sorry we're very grateful
yeah thank you you know blm
your country has an entirely different
history and context for its
uh relationship between uh uh
police officers and citizens it's also
the history of
black citizens here so but for some
reason blm has taken root here anyways
and
um this is why it's it really is a
worldwide
threat i think to liberal democracy
and um the damage that it's been able to
do
in just a mere three and a half years
uh has been immense and the issues are
not going away
uh even after trump has lost we still
had continued riots
there are multiple cities that had new
coordinated new year's eve riots
uh we're likely it's going to continue
because all like i said before
all the variables are there in
the so-called threat of fascism from the
trump administration was
always uh of a pre-tax just
an excuse used to ex
excuse her violent extremist behaviors
but if it's not one thing it's another
thing
you know if it's not trump it's police
if it's not police it's america itself
well you see them defacing uh democratic
politicians homes homes now with things
scribbling cancel rent and all this
other stuff on that that's right
yeah we had they
this is what i've been trying so i i
hope that
some people on the liberal left in
america will read my book because
this threat to america is not just a
threat to the american
right it's really going at the heart
of american institutions which
includes democrat party so we've had
for example on city council in portland
one
one of the new city council members uh
they were auntie for rioters who showed
up to his home and began breaking things
because as punishment for him voting
against
defunding further portland police and he
and he's a left-winger
so you know they have these extremists
they have no issues
targeting the left when they want to
and they do do it so
their own stated goal is to essentially
abolish america abolish nation states
francis did you know that investing is
one of the best ways to preserve your
wealth over the long term
what's well something you will never
find out as long as i have control of
the trigonometry account
however if you do have wealth high
commission and clunky products
from traditional stock brokers make it
very difficult for people like me
to start investing good for everyone
else though
free trade has come up with an
award-winning app that is currently
being used by over 250
000 people it's fca approved and fscs
protected it's brilliant it allows you
to trade commission free
free trade has won best online trading
platform at the british bank awards
two years in a row 2019 and 2020.
they offer no speculative products no
spread betting no day trading
it's all about preserving and growing
your wealth over long term
no hidden fees transparent price and
structure very simple to use
you can sign up for a general investment
account or a stocks and shares
isa or sign up to free trade plus for
more advanced order types and a bigger
stock
universe they've also got other new
products coming soon you can get a
universe
go to free trade dot io trigger register
and fund your account
and you'll get a randomly allocated free
share
worth between three and two hundred
pounds could be in a great company like
right move apple even greg's great so
when you invest your capital is at risk
the value of your investments can go up
as well as down and you may receive back
less than you originally invested you
knew that bit off by heart
and andy one thing that i really wanted
to tap into is obviously your
vietnamese heritage vietnam obviously
has a
very very long and troubled history with
the far left communism in particular
do you think that is the reason you that
you were more sensitive
to these particular groups and you were
able to see through
their modus operandi as it were whereas
american people who are your age or
below have no real
knowledge of far-left politics and the
danger that these particular groups can
cause
yeah you know um
journalists are trained to remove
yourself from the story
for good reason right you don't want to
make yourself part of the story on
things that you're reporting on
but for me as i was writing about antifa
going back several years
i just found that it was extremely hard
to sort of
um entirely remove myself in that my
family's experience
living through a communist revolution
going to prison camps
being persecuted for political entirely
for political reasons
um it mirrors a lot of
what i'm seeing people on the american
far left
stating that they want to do essentially
um isn't that an exaggeration andy
are they really saying we want to put
people in camps are they really saying
we need to
uh you know put someone in prison for 25
years for having the wrong political
view are they really saying that is that
when you embed yourself in their protest
is that what they're talking about
no it's not exaggeration they've killed
people over political disagreements
important and they've tried to kill and
gotten themselves killed as well
people who science was not a deadly
movement let's look at what they've done
okay in 2019
you had a man named and i write about
this in the book
um charles landers this is in eugene
oregon it's a small college town
very left-wing he shortly before going
to a school and launching an attempted
shooting on school resource officers
they
had written anti-police stuff on his
facebook killed police killed pigs
and he was deeply involved in the antifa
movement in eugene and he got killed in
the process of his attack
you had later in the year billam fans
bronson which is in tacoma washington
state
he firebombed a immigration
facility and came to armed with a rifle
he got killed in the process but blew up
a car
there was conor betz in ohio who killed
nine people
in a mass shooting who had a has had a
long
history of nancy for activism including
in being in the black bloc
and just months ago in portland we had
somebody who
quote this was in his instagram
manifesto i am 100
auntie for following a trump supporter
in downtown portland
waiting around the corner and bushing
him and shooting him dead
right in the middle of downtown and
fleeing to another state before getting
killed by federal authorities
so so but andy those are all individual
cases which
i completely un obviously very sad and
shouldn't be encouraged at all but that
doesn't necessarily mean
that because there's a few wackos in in
the movement uh
that those people are then you know
they're representative of the ideas
behind the movement that so what we were
talking about initially is
your vietnamese background and look as
someone who came was born in the soviet
union francis as well his parents
mother being from venezuela we get all
this right but what i'm trying to get at
is
are they actually saying we need to
create gulags for wrong thinkers
they are saying that um when they aren't
explicitly calling for their political
opponents to be killed
yeah i mean you just look look at how
they treat dissidents
uh so-called dissidents of people who
they suspect of
not being completely on the side in
areas where they've claimed territory
they beat up journalists in their
so-called autonomous zones
you know they even had uh one of my
friends in acquaintance
who was recording video in the seattle
autonomous zone
he they saw him with the camera and they
tried to pull him into an interrogation
tent that they had set up there and he
was literally an interrogation tent
might not be quite as friendly as you're
pretending right yeah so his name is
kaelin
or midas you can go online and look at
his testimony for that but i mean police
were called he was
like dragged on the street literally
before being escaped
so you you know you don't just have to
look at what they say you look at their
actions
they even though they say they are
against governments what essentially
they do want to create is a totalitarian
system essentially where there's because
their opposition is not just to people
who
say things that they disagree with they
don't want you to think differently
which is why they spend
so much effort in getting people banned
off social media so exploiting the
left-wing bias that is
prevalent on in big tech social media
companies
getting their opposition banned um
getting them fired doxing them releasing
information where they live
uh work etc and and terrorizing their
opponents so
i don't think you know there are there's
a certain amount of
parallels and yes there are differences
obviously with like the vietnamese
communist regime
from uh the american context
but broadly it is about a revolutionary
far less politics
about achieving their goals by any means
necessary including violence
including i think i actually know if
they had the power they would imprison
their
political opponents if they didn't kill
them outright
because you just look at their actions
on a small scale level and look when
when they've actually had gain
power temporarily in child or importance
autonomously and what they do
to people have you ever been abroad and
felt out of place because you didn't
speak the language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that sometimes you're abroad you
don't speak the local language it's very
awkward like france is talking to a
woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babel is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers
a clear and easy to use interface they
have daily 10 to 15 minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies showing that you can learn
up to 14 languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up
or maybe you're just english right now
babel is offering
our fans six months free on a six-month
subscription
with babel using our special code which
is of course
trigger that's babble b a b
b e l dot co dot
u k slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel i did
but seriously go to babble.co dot uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
and andy who is a typical member of
antifa do they tend to be from one
particular background or another or are
they spread far and wide from every
echelon of society it is spread
far and wide one myth that i do want to
dispel is that they're all
middle class uh
wealthy people that's uh some of them
are upper class as well
yeah some of them do represent people
who are university educated in
white-collar jobs
absolutely and actually the antivirus
was so
furious that i was publicizing these
booking public records
of these booking photos from these uh
six months of arrests in portland
because
you know it exposed that some of them
were in white collar jobs such as
being nurses being doctors being
professors
being academics being university
students at private
expensive elite institutions there's all
that
but i would say it really it includes
this is what i mean this ideology does
appeal to
people who are do well in america and as
well as people who are really vulnerable
and this is kind of where my i have
a certain i don't know if compassion is
right where it's sympathy
for some of these people who are used as
tools
foot soldiers in these mass rights
people who are many of them are vagrants
a lot of them are dealing with mental
health issues a lot of them
are have gender dysphoria
and they're being pulled into a
ideology movement that promises then
community
meaning purpose uh belonging i mean you
have a uniform you have a
identity and label that you go under as
a
anti-fascist so-called anti-fascists
and they have a lot of literature as
well booklets
pamphlets like if you read my book on
mass you'll see that
the radicalization process is really
important in antifa it's a lot of
brainwashing actually and it takes a lot
of brainwashing to get
people who go from broadly being
sympathetic to some of these things
let's say racial justice
to eventually being one of the people
who mask up and bring let's say knives
or tasers
or molotov cocktails and other firebombs
to these riots with the intent
um to kill people and this process
happens
um not spontaneously but through these
radicalizations
and how does it happen tell us more
about that just take us through i am a
sort of distance
as andy yeah radicalize this entirety
for life on it
no but seriously so here i am i'm
disaffected with society
i'm very progressive in my mindset maybe
i'm i've got some mental health issues i
here i am i've come in and you are your
job is to get me to the point where i'm
ready to go on a riot
how does that happen so there are let's
say i say in portland they have it down
to an art
there are the street militants and then
there are other
antifa groups who don't explicitly
engage
in street violence but they'll do things
like
community events support uh supportive
like direct action where they do things
that ostensibly look like charity work
just distributing food to those in their
community
um protesting peacefully all
that if you go to any of these events in
addition to
the food and supplies that they're
distributing for free
they will always have tables
of their booklets and it's very similar
actually to
i would say like a radicalization
process of like the muslim brotherhood
or other
islamists or even jihadists really you
introduce them to certain theories
theories about why why capitalism
is inherently linked to racism
how it's connected to slavery and how
america
as in protecting capitalism property
free markets um is
uh in imperialist state of racism that
support
that um upholds white supremacy like
in a lot of these ideas are actually um
they're
in academic and intellectual and they're
simplified in these booklets and
pamphlets that are given out
um nelly bowls for the new york report
at new york times who
went up to portland to cover some of
these violent protest riots in portland
wrote about some of these booklets and
pamphlets and antifa were really angry
about that sort of like national
spotlight that it brought to it but
there's very few people paying attention
because if you walk by you do think it's
just another table
of just like things that people are
handing out that actually forms a very
important part in their um
how they're introducing what they call
radical ideas to others
and in chats they have the same thing in
the recent autonomous zone in portland
so you know you you start building
friendships these friends start
introducing these
extremist ideas they have gatherings and
meetings in the case of
road city antifa which my book publishes
some of the documents for the first time
they will actually have a
curriculum that's really kind of like a
university curriculum now they'll meet
weekly
uh in a secret place they'll have a set
of literature they
and they're each week you're supposed to
read they'll discuss it
um and what are some of the central
themes so i've come i've got a pamphlet
i've got my sandwich i've got my
pamphlet i'm like okay well yeah there
are problems with capitalism maybe it's
because america is inherently racist or
whatever
now i've come to the meeting for the
first time what what are you telling me
to get me into that the main themes or
the main points of their
radical ideas that they're trying to
brainwash people into believing
is that non-violence
empowers the state and the state
enforces fascism
um that uh property rights
is linked to racism linked to a system
of white supremacy
so these two things hatred of a nation
in hatred of
property rights those are probably the
two main ideas
and they have a particular hatred for
law enforcement
because they view law enforcement well
as the literal enforcers
of the rules of this world right if the
state is fascist
they are then the fascist boots on the
ground and enforcing the fascist laws
so this whole using black lives matter
in opposition to police is just
it's it's been a very convenient and
perfect way for them to make their
really extreme ideas
palatable to a wider public
and they've had immense success i mean
look at the calls to
defund and abolish police happening in
city councils across america
and andy they don't also it's not just a
process of indoctrination
mentally but also physically they get
taught how to fight they get taught how
to
uh various other things as well could
you delve into that for us
so the really organized militant
antifa groups are extremely secretive
because
i mean they they explicitly they have
a membership process and in in all
intents and purposes they are again
and they will plan out criminal violent
activity
so they keep all the activities secret
and in a press and media who
unfortunately are very not curious have
not dived into trying to uncover really
how they organized
i mean in my book i was able to acquire
the documentation
from the oldest american antifa group
which is rose city antifa
now absolutely if you look at their
documentations their emails to one
another
it completely blows over this claim that
antifa
is not doesn't exist as an organization
that they're not organized
i mean the thing is antifa is not one
entity there are many many antifa groups
there are networks of them the torch
network
is the network that's probably the most
violently militant
uh rose city antifa is part of that but
they have chapters in
seven other cities so
there's a blueprint for how they
organize and
um i think that's what was really
shocking about the the curriculum for
rose state and antifa which you can read
in detail in the book is that
they were holding these secret meetings
at a bookstore in portland
so on the outside it looks so innocuous
you would never
think that a feminist bookstore
was allowing its space to be used by
extremists literal violent extremists i
would say
it's it's a terrorist ideology actually
you know they
they spend so much time into
brainwashing their members that
violence is a necessity to achieve their
goals
but you're saying they're a terrorist
ideology but in your book
what's very very interesting is that you
examine the antecedents of antifa
and the fact is like everything under
the sun this is nothing new
there was i think the biden meinhof uh
group in the 60s but there was also
uh the far left and the far right
organization in weimar in germany in the
pre in the into war years
could you explain to us a little bit
about that as well um
so since trump has come into office the
uh
american press the international press
and in western countries has gone
really overdrive until focusing entirely
on this
on um threats to violence
that come from the far right in white
races
in really fringe small neo-nazi groups
and that threat is absolutely there but
it is small but that's
all that they paid attention to america
has had
a history of far-left violent extremism
that
a lot of young people people my age
aren't aware of
the violence that we had in the 60s and
70s
um which was uh quelled or squashed
because of law enforcement uh
imprisoning these some of these members
um charging them many of them fled
abroad to cuba where they were given
um uh refugee status there
so america has had a history of
far-left voluntary streams people who
killed law enforcement who
carried out bombings for example um
germany as well and so
there's this history
in building blocks that antifa takes
from
to do what they're able to do today and
there's just this
a gap in the collective american memory
i would say
how far left extremism that they think
and and that is actually quite
intentional i would say about the media
they really
they downplay and they ignore it
entirely i mean
you know you can contrast let's say two
mass shootings that we had in 2019 in
the us
so there was a um reportedly
far-right racist white supremacists in
texas
who killed some 20-something people out
of walmart and the people were majority
of uh
latino background and that received a
lot of media attention not one because
it was
a mass killing and two because of the um
potential racist links and
allegations relating to that but within
24 hours after that shooting we had the
mass shooting in ohio from conor bets
who i talked about a moment ago
an auntie from mass shooter who he
looked through his social media history
was
not just identified as part of it but
like explicitly calling for violence
against
the right um he carried out a mass
shooting and that
didn't get as much attention or much
attention at all
and is that all about trump andy is it
is is this what happened 2016
trump's gets elected media uh shocked
not only because
he's he is a shocking figure to to
people on on the sort of uh
liberal what you you guys call it
liberal we don't call it liberal here
but
on the left let's say uh if you're a
left-wing person in the media to you the
election of donald trump is a shock to
the system
and you're going well he needs to be got
rid of
by any means necessary so you're sort of
like yeah okay look
this stuff may be happening but let's
just focus on getting rid of donald
trump is that is that what happened
it is what happened uh i think trump the
rain trump derangements and
syndrome is real and you particularly
saw it in journalists journalists who
before his election led long
distinguished careers and at times may
have been biased but not
to the level of what i would call really
unprofessional behavior and reporting
that you see now
so surely with that in mind you alluded
to to your opinion about this earlier
but
trump you know he's gone right we've got
a brilliant new you know mixed race
ticket uh racism is over
everything's going to be wonderful uh
there is no more need for street
violence because we're going to fix all
the bad stuff
[Music]
if only if only that was the case the
thing is
if you've been paying attention to the
rhetoric of blm and antifa
particularly throughout 2020 it is
shifted
very clearly away from opposition to
trump to opposition to
the united states itself so they're not
going to be satisfied until they can
destroy anything and everything they can
so um you know they have goals that
really can
not ever really be achieved in that
if it's not one issue that they are
protesting against it's another
and if it's not that it's another after
that it's it's these people who can
never
ever be satisfied i mean when you say
you are
against white supremacy and fascism and
you define it
in the way they define it which includes
anything and everything
that means their goals can never be
achieved so they are always going to
have a reason
to be violent they found a reason to be
violent in portland and
uh atlanta and other cities on new
year's eve
you know because it's the new years the
new years to renew our dedication to
fighting fascism and racism so we're
going to riot
we're going to bring weapons to downtown
portland so
um and i mean if it's not clear enough
that this is
antifungal violent extremist dangerous
movement you can just
look at like who they say
that they are inspired by and take
influence from which is the original
antifa which was
a paramilitary of the german communist
party
so that was the original anti-funder
logos that you see today of the flags
was
is based off a design from that
originally so the original
paramilitary of the german antifa they
were engaging in
street fights in germany not just
against the brown shirts and fascists
but actually the social democrats
they're
fighting and beating up all political
opponents and they were creating this
political climate of political
polarization
in germany and in towards germany and
making the wider public just wanting all
that street political violence to end
and i think some academics have posited
that that
context helped pave the way for
the appeal of somebody like a hitler
so so what you're saying is these people
aren't really anti-fascists they're
pro-anarchy
and chaos yes yes
and i actually i think a lot of them are
probably upset that trump's going out
because they really
they they use that so well as an excuse
to get to bring in new allies
but they carefully have now switched the
enemy from trump
to law enforcement and
they've been successful in bringing out
people there and so you know all it
really takes
is just a very simple video
of some unfortunate incident that has
been taken out of context
to mobilize not just thousands but tens
of thousands of people
uh not just in my country but your
country as well in other countries
around the world
um that's how effective their messaging
has been
and although biden is a
more moderate democrat you just
you look at the people who have
influence in the democratic party people
like aoc
people like ilhan omar the radicals
people who are just
state rep representatives in congress
you know one of many
but they have such an outsize and large
influence on the party
that their messaging
will is going to play into the decisions
of the dnc
in my opinion in my predictions and andy
how do we defeat them
so you've we've explained it we've
looked at the type of people who
are involved in this ideology the fact
that they're anarchists that they want
chaos that they thrive on this
obviously it is not in our interest or
anybody's interest that these people are
successful
so how do we defeat number one the group
and number two the ideology
that's actually easier to defeating the
movement itself means is essentially
doing what's been done in the past so
how law enforcement were able in the u.s
to end the terrorism
far-left communist revolutionaries in
the 70s were
to arrest prosecute
in jail those who were involved in the
criminal activities
and that hugely disrupted their networks
as well unfortunately all these people
have been
released from prison and have been
reincorporated into
left-wing activism and their their
past actions people just look over
there and then pass criminal actions
so there's that you don't necessarily
need new laws
although i think
let's say in your country you have laws
that
prescribe certain organizations and
groups
that are applied to jihadist groups for
example and far-right groups
i think that should be applied to
far-left groups
uh in america we don't have those type
of laws because
of how strong our first amendment is you
know anything that could be
interpreted as um
persecuting people for the beliefs even
if there are
violent extremist beliefs you can have
those
radical beliefs it's protected by the
first amendment that's why it's not
it's not illegal to be a member of the
neo-nazi group it's not
illegal to be a member of the violent
antifa group
so what needs to happen is
the rioters are being arrested though
they're not
being held accountable so this is an
issue with
prosecutors being elected and i'm not
quite sure what the solution would be
but obviously it means people waking up
and realizing that
going soft on rioters just because they
say they're doing it in a noble cause
like that
that this really requires a paradigm
shift i think in the american mind
so that we elect prosecutors who
actually uphold the law
and do you think it's a question of
education andy the fact that
most americans don't know about
communism like we touched on before
you know they haven't been educated
about it the dangers and the evils of
the far left
yes absolutely there's just not a lot of
knowledge people aren't really aware
that we had uh
far-left communist marxist cells in the
70s that were doing kidnappings and bank
robberies and killing law enforcement
and carrying out ex bombing attacks they
just don't know about that whereas you
know anytime you ask them about
right toward extremism everybody can
remember things
and they don't let things go and
you know this is somewhat related uh
it's just like
um heather heyer who who was killed in
in charlottesville like her name is
regularly mentioned and it should be
mentioned because i think her life
didn't matter
[Music]
but aaron danielson which is the person
who was shot in portland nobody knows
his name nobody remembers him nobody
honors them none of the politicians
uttered his name in portland
when that killing happened so it's just
and it was because he was killed by
somebody who explicitly said he was
antifa
so do you think that's it there's a
there's a lack of moral equivalence
between the two because
a far right extremist is viewed as as
the most evil thing you can think of
they're racist they're prejudiced
they're bigoted
you tired to slavery in your mind all of
that sort of stuff whereas if it's
someone on the far left it's easier to
excuse because you're going well they're
probably well intentioned aren't they
they just want everyone to be
like there's that lack of um
judging an act on the basis of the act
because we
we buy into this idea that this murderer
is better than that murderer because
this murderer
actually used some kind of good
motivation for their violence
well that and that's the problem the
problem uh
reinforced by the media is that
um that it's wrong to
criticize both these the far left and
far right in the same breath because
they're not
they can't be compared because the far
left even if they are violent they are
doing it for
racial justice for equity that
i mean you know you you go down that
path of thinking the ratio the rational
conclusion is
it does lead to violent anti-for
extremism or
any other type of marxist terrorism um
because it's like well it's for this
cause right the cause of
um uh the proletariat the because
of oppressed racial minorities it's okay
to kill police it's okay to
advocate for violence against these
people because
you know we're fighting for a noble
cause and
for me it's really immaterial really
what the
goal is that the if the actions that are
carried out lead to
violence murder terrorism
so uh i think i'm being consistent in my
condemnation in the far left and the far
right i wish the media would be
too um and i think the other thing is
that
um you know put me personally
experiencing
the the threats that come from antifa
that are directed at me make it
more personal because then it's real
like antifa will write
murder and you know around the city of
portland and that graffiti stays up
in their autonomous zone recently in
portland they wrote my name
and an address and that stayed up so
it's it's unfortunate that there isn't
very much solidarity with me from
other people who are in the same field
and actually it's a lot of other
journalists who frequently
condemn me and delegitimize my work but
you know if any
any journalist even just some
contributor to small publication
received
explicit threats from a neo-nazi the
whole industry would rally against that
person
and all the press organizations would as
well
i mean i've i've reported my threats to
press freedom tracker
and other groups and they used to
get back to me they don't anymore maybe
because it's become too frequent uh
report all this stuff to law enforcement
they don't do anything
um so
so is that why you've moved to the uk
i've had to flee uh my country my home
because of the ongoing threats
and the lack of action from law
enforcement even when
through my own investigations i've been
able to identify some of these people
i mean people who pose with guns and say
that
bullets need to be put in me all this
type of stuff
prosecutors choosing not to prosecute i
mean
you know in my beauty last year you and
i we talked
just a few months after my beating last
year
at that time i was optimistic that they
would lead to arrests
no um you know we through my own uh
legal counsel this legal fund by the way
center for american liberty we had to
finance our own private investigation
put in
hundreds of our own hours into
uncovering some of these people
and then once that information was
provided to police
and the attorney general nothing was
done
so unfortunately we're having to sue
them to the civil route when these
people should be actually held
criminally responsible and probably look
we can talk about you know the academic
side of it and you know the you know the
fact
you know on the left and people don't
want to condemn people on there for a
variety of reasons
and look isn't part of it just the fact
that they're cowards
isn't it just simple cowardice as well
because it's difficult to do the right
thing it's difficult to stand up to a
bully
and go you're wrong yes i have
encountered
a lot of cowards unfortunately doing the
line of work that i do
even i mean
this is this is the issue of um
you know and you two are not partisan
but i i myself am a conservative i think
because of the political
hegemony that the left has in particular
in journalism
they make it quite consequent
consequential
for people who are critical of the left
even the far left
and i don't know what it'll take for
that to change
i mean and i don't want the inverse to
happen by the way i don't
i don't i would not want to work in an
industry let's say that was dominated
by the right and a right that was
unwilling to
[Music]
condemn far-right extremism
right so a moment ago you had asked
what does it take to um defeat antifa
ideologically
and i think it's you know hopefully
through efforts like what i am doing
with unmasked
in this book where i spent months and
months
at sort of the american epicenter events
for violence looking at
not just how they organize how they get
some of their funding
how they carry out coordinate and mass
violence but looking actually what do
they actually believe
what does it mean when they say that
they are opposing
um capitalism when they're opposing u.s
imperialism
opposing white supremacy what's that
actually mean what are they actually
advocating for
and then we've had now you know
a very clear view into what happens when
the ideology is actually implemented
in a territory and it does lead
to death violence the confiscation of
property
i mean in the portland autonomous zone
this is really this didn't get much
as much media attention as the chaz but
they actually
create so they created their own
barricades like what they did in chat so
they actually had a defined territory
they built a wall you could say
they built a wall and then they built a
buffer zone that was growing every day
every day it was moving further and
further out
and they start booby traps in the street
literal booby traps
spikes um they were laying out boards
with
hat needle um nails sticking up so you
could
you couldn't drive in they had strategic
points where they
had bottles um molotov cocktails
rocks that they could use as sort of
their like attack areas
like and they were doing this
and this was the official messaging was
that they were protecting
a black indigenous family from being
removed from their home from being
evicted from their home in the winter
it was absolute rubbish it was a lie
with a family who had been squatting
at a property that they didn't pay
anything for for three years since 2017
and that the legal process had been
played out court judgment after court
judgment appeals rejected et cetera et
cetera these people were
illegally squatting and this this is the
people who and
they had stockpiled weapons inside this
property
and so this is the type of people that
they protect and then the media just
goes along with
protecting a black indigenous family
from the eviction in the winter
yeah the coverage of of this issue is i
mean it's been embarrassing from from
mainstream
publications but which is why we're
grateful to have people like you who can
come and talk about it and as you say
you know francis and i are not partisan
on this issue but we are partisan on
non-violence we're partisan on the rule
of law i mean i think everyone should be
partisan on on that sort of thing
very right wing of yours very very it's
extremely right-wing well it is seen as
a right-wing position
yeah yeah according to you know people
who follow like critical race theory and
all that yeah
well yeah i mean if logically i can see
it if you think the state is fascist
and if you think property rights or
fascism then evicting someone from a
property where they're squatting
is a is fascism under that definition
to normal people it makes no sense of
course but as francis said earlier i
think
a lot of people simply don't know what
they get involved with
to a lot of people all of this stuff is
simply about ensuring justice and
equality
and those of us who try and sort of
point out some of the underpinnings of
this
uh immediately get boxed into you know
all sorts of categories but
there's nothing we can do about it what
we can do andy is thank you for coming
back on the show
uh it's a pleasure it's good to see you
are well and safe here
uh in in this country for now hopefully
this stuff doesn't come over too much
it's been good to have you back and as
you know we've got one more question for
you which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society but
we really should be
i like that uh sees this particular
question then i'm very sure
um i wasn't prepared for it last year
and i don't think i'm
that prepared this time either but i
think i have a better answer
i just i think we need to be panicking
about this
erosion in the norm of non-violence
in western liberal democracies like
it's not by chance that we have come to
a civilization
in a standard norm that you don't
resolve
disagreements through through violence
against others and
there has been a very quick and
systematic erosion of that just as a
norm not through the laws
that laws haven't changed in that regard
but i mean
when politics is downstream from from
culture quoting andrew breitbart
so we're moving into a direction of a
culture
where more and more people are believing
that the response
to grievances is to be violent and
destructive
we shouldn't just be talking about that
or we should be panicking about it
in my opinion that sounds that sounds
like something we can all fight for
good point i love it when francis does a
joke and the guest just
he looks at him it's it's a great ending
to show andy
thank you so much for coming back all
the best with your book it's out on the
2nd of february
yes it's on the 2nd of february it's
called unmasked make sure you get it
it's a brilliant read there's a
historical perspective
and as we've just talked about andy has
been on the ground documenting all this
stuff
so make sure you get unmasked on the 2nd
of february and we will see you very
soon with another brilliant interview
like this one
this is probably going to be our last in
person interview for a while so we hope
you've enjoyed
it and we will see you very soon
7 p.m for a live stream or another
interview thank you very much guys see
you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below